principio de acuerdo para sancionar
altos cargos del gobierno ruso se trata
de personas que hayan participado en el
encarcelamiento del líder opositor
alexéi navalni recordemos que tras ser
envenenado regreso a su país y aquel y
fue encarcelado la intención es que tras
el acuerdo y llegado hoy de estas
sanciones pueden entrar en vigor en
marzo que quedan esas dos semanas se
trata sobre todo de prohibir la entrada
de estas personas sancionadas a
territorio europeo pero también la
congelación de bienes que tengan dentro
de la unión europea esto se produce
justo después del polémico viaje del
jefe de la diplomacia europea de aburren
que viajó a moscú a principios de
febrero y en que se pudo palpar la
tensión entre bruselas y moscú de hecho
varios países europeos aseguran que ha
sido un punto de inflexión entre ambas
potencias y que esto ha podido acelerar
también las sanciones pero como
comentabas éstas no han sido las únicas
sanciones que se han aprobado hoy
en bruselas porque también se han
aprobado sancionar a 19 altos cargos del
gobierno de nicolás maduro tras las
elecciones legislativas del pasado 6 de
diciembre
en total se han sancionado ya a 55
personas en venezuela porque se
considera que las elecciones
legislativas del pasado diciembre no
fueron libres o fueron justas ni tampoco
fueron democráticas y que por lo tanto
la unión europea debía actuar pero sin
que afectara ello a la población de
venezuela aun así bruselas insiste en
que hay que aumentar en mantener el
diálogo y que uno de los principales
interlocutores sigue siendo juan guaidó
esther nos queda poco tiempo pero no
quiero dejar de preguntar te ponían mar
no porque el bloque está apuntando
contra la junta militar que se va a cabo
el golpe del primero de febrero
sí así es han aprobado a sancionar a la
junta militar aún no se ha especificado
exactamente a quién pero lo cierto es
que no también las las últimas los
últimos sucesos del pasado fin de semana
especialmente sangriento y de represión
contra los manifestantes han asegurado
los cancilleres que es momento de estar
preparando ya sanciones tras este golpe
de estado